he has been involved with ESPN's
coverage for a very long time for the
for the draft and he will be front and
center one week from tonight as it was a
bet video that came out today was quite
something with him sitting on the set
and Tom Brady getting drafted and Tirico
being the one to do it
I cannot believe it's been 20 years as
he's getting better
ready for yet another draft on the set
for ESPN he is Mel Kiper jr. how are you
Mel bridge great to talk to you pal it
has been amazingly 20 years since pretty
was that remember when the pick was made
I mean and and seeing the video today
what how did that hit in the wayback
machine hit you right there Mel telling
you rich years ago by pretty quick don't
say I mean I I just remember thinking
after it was all over and Brady was well
you know we're developing into one the
best of all time that they didn't even
take sin with us their first pick in the
sixth round they took Antwan Harris a
defensive back out of Virginia and then
I'm a resurgent win went at a Southwest
Texas state to the Cleveland Browns and
then here's Brady a compensatory pick at
the into the sixth round 199 pick
overall you're going to New England but
if you go back rich knew anyone got
nothing had that dress really except for
Brady exactly I mean and that's but
that's enough with one guy exactly what
was your first grab by the way 37 years
ago this is your 37th draft that you're
you're involved in what was the first
one like four you know which one was
that it's crazy
well I covered the draft in 78 79
putting out the reports and doing all
that first of all with ESPN was the 83
season 84 draft know I remember rich was
going up to Bristol was just one
building wrinkled building and Chris
Berman and Bob Lee greeted me at the
door took me down to the studio and you
know it was it was done then you know
it's basically the first round we got
into the second round and we signed off
and I just remembered to win round one
and boomers are saying hey I've never
done much TV I was 20 what 23 years old
they say just just talk to me we're
sitting at a - just talk to me bob was
the host there and Chris and I were
sitting in a desk and we just did our
thing they came we weren't on the main
set the main set was in New Yor
with George grande and Howard balls were
in Paul Zimmerman so we would come they
were come to us and with the rare thing
and then would send it back to New York
but it was was fun but I remember is
thinking back to then and now second
round we were signing off to go to like
a boat race or a tractor pull I bet I
bet I just remember I was in college
mill watching it at the University of
Michigan watching the draft with you and
I just remember cuz you know all my
fraternity brothers who are from the
Midwest knew I was one of the few New
Yorkers in the in the mix and then when
the Jets drafted Jeff Locke I mean and
you went all in against it they just
they were just cool they were quoting
you directly to my face no back in the
day those were the days I've lent them
to trade down and still get lager many
yeah it's amazing how back in those days
you know we weren't doing and I remember
Freddie Goodell II sitting there or rich
back in whatever year it was Iraq where
we come down on the second day of the
track we just relax and and you know
just casually sit there with arimin
write down the pics and Freddie was
sitting there I so Freddie why are you
hanging out on day two so long he said
I'm just scoping this out because next
year
we're televising every back and now
you've done that you know you've been
doing that but back in those days never
thought going what was talked about in
terms of draft and the NFL didn't even
want it to be televised all of a sudden
you'd go from a few rounds to all the
rounds and every pick and that was when
Freddie told me that I was pretty amazed
by I said boy this trap is coming off a
long way hasn't it it sure has
now here we are in 2020 and it is
something that I think the entire United
States of America I'll be honest and I
know this is saying a lot I think I
think we need it Mel I think we need it
I think we needed his people to just sit
down getting emotional just even saying
this right now I never thought I'd get
emotional over an NFL Draft but I think
we do Mel I think the whole country
needs it already yeah I talk to a lot of
people you know on the phone mostly
because you don't have a lot of contact
now except with family and yeah you
think about you know people saying hey
you know it's to get our mind off this
and just have something to focus on
other than what's going on in the world
in this country it's just horrible and
and I think this is the first we never
thought we'd see it but we see and we're
living through it but I think for people
to just sit there and watch something
that looks a normal looks like things
there I've continually had to calm
and this all happened in March so at
least I got the combine in and here we
are with the draft as scheduled on April
23rd and we're gonna have players picked
and there was a TV event it was never a
fan event it was always just a TV event
that's what it will be here we'll be all
be on-air in our home was doing it
whenever globe point whatever we're
doing it on and it all happened and I
think for fans they want I've talked to
so many people even with free agency
rich they wanted free agency to continue
gave them something to focus on there so
I think it does yeah will contribute to
the I'd say the mental state of a lot of
people who need this as a diversion to
get away from what's going on and
especially since I think the the initial
shock from the scouting community there
may be some as well in the town
evaluation community and the management
in the air at the team level about like
not doing the draft in the manner in
which they're accustomed to in a draft
room with everything at their fingertips
and a full medical that's in front of
them that I think that that's wearing
off and I think teams are ready now I'm
wondering if you feel the same way on
that front I know I do talking to them
they're ready to go there's some concern
about your technology and how it will
work there's some concern about if you
want to make a trade and you don't have
your guys in your room to get the eye
contact with and and the hand gestures
to say hey you know up or down thumbs up
something you can figure it out by that
you can't now but they're ready to go
most teams are ready to go early I think
they often I said this back then there's
what's going on now to just have a
giraffe get it done I mean our first
responders think about the doctors the
nurses I like my own family nurses and
doctors out there putting their lives at
risk to help everybody and deal with
everybody that's sick and where things
they are so there's a lot more important
things to deal with and worrying about
how you're going to pick a player and
ironically the best dress in the history
of the NFL were 1971 in 1974 by the
Pittsburgh Steelers when they directed
Hall of Famer some of which came from
small schools and then you didn't have
all this information you didn't have
rechecks and this and that and
everything you have now and the over
analysis that you have rich so they I
think they get back now to may be
drafting a little bit better because
they're looking at players as opposed to
looking at workout Mel Kiper jr. getting
ready for his 37th NFL Draft with ESPN
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
let's get into the tool evaluation where
one we
from from the actual result what is his
evaluation right now that you're hearing
and think might actually play out one
week from tonight no well you know I did
the mock the other day and I had him
going 6 to LA Chargers with Herbert
going Justin Herbert Ark and quarterback
going 5 to Miami it's just base written
as you know what you hear from the
people you talk to we don't talk to 32
teams you know we have a handful or
teams to talk to and everybody's gonna
have different opinions based on who
they talk to
now those teams feel about what they're
hearing and no team is ever going to
tell you who they're picking or who they
like and who they don't like us it's not
going to happen for the most part so I
think you look at Miami and the Chargers
if he goes to the Chargers at six it's
no big deal now the big deal would be if
he slips a little throw something he
could many teams are preparing for the
possibility that could happen we've had
it happen before
for no really an explainable reason to
go back to Aaron Rodgers oh he was
thinking about two weeks before that's
wrapped we thought he'd go number one he
go Alex Smith goes number one instead of
Aaron and here's Aaron sliding down into
20s that has happened before so and they
think it could maybe happen here so what
you're hearing more so than the injury
is how he will be once he's in the
league will he be able to hold up
protect his body take hits and be an
Ironman a quarterback people say well
there's injuries everybody well not a
quarterback rich quarterbacks a position
where you can have guys get Eli look at
rivers you know look at the Ray Brady go
back to Elway Marino Kelly I mean they
played forever now they had an injury
here and there but it wasn't something
that was you were worried about you know
durability in terms of playing in year
to year you might have an injury once
every 10 years but not like two has had
at Alabama so that's the concern
hopefully we'll be able to stay healthy
if he does have a great career
you would think based on what we saw at
Alabama well if this is the your way of
getting your reporting in and also your
evaluation and marrying it together to
be as accurate as you think it might be
from mock to reality let's just remove
the reporting from it I mean you're
straight up evaluation of two of versus
Herbert would be what no but it's easy
for me to do that because I don't have
to make that kick I think what I said
today on ESPN was this rich if you're
picking five or six how do you reconcile
that how do you say okay I'm okay with
risk/reward
knowing the injury question is real
knowing the hip knowing the other
injuries that he's had
is real you say that with this in mind
that at five and six if he's healthy you
don't get him you have to trade up give
up draft capital which is in their case
of Miamian the charges are probably two
or three starters to maybe move up and
get them if everything would have been
perfect with tua now it's not perfect so
you get him at five or six by not even
having the move and then you don't have
the rest day what's the right we would
have never seen him here had it not been
for that so I think that's the way to
talk to your owner about why it's worth
the risk at five or six now if he gets
into and that's if he doesn't go five or
six then you get into the fourth quarter
back actually then in that case will be
the third quarter back which makes it a
tough situation because if burrow goes
one which we expect that to be a lot to
be number one corporate goes five and
two is sitting there you know where is
he dropping two teams don't really need
quarterbacks in that area now to go to
your question about two as a quarterback
the only concern would be that four
first-round receivers around him a
first-round right tackle
yeah Damien Harris yet Josh Jacobs and
he had Nagi Harris and he had all these
great but Smith last year I mean two
years ago I was a first-round pick so he
had a ton of town around him during his
career but his precise accurate passing
being a left-handed drew brees which is
why I've always referred to him is there
and that's why he's got a high grade but
I think today it'll be interesting to
see a five or six or does he slip a
little further and then what team makes
the move to get him Mel Kiper junior
here on the Rich Eisen show your
evaluation of love is what what's your
evaluation of this kid he can spin it as
well as any quarterback and he had a
great year two seasons ago with the 32
touchdown passes six picks when he had
talent around them this year they took
the talents of talent left I mean you
can't take five receivers top running
back for starters on the line away from
a kid at Utah State we said that about
Josh Allen at Wyoming his final year it
took his top guys away from him Darnell
had a lot of his top guys taking away
from him his final year so that's why it
was tough for him to even come close to
duplicating 2018 and he didn't he had 17
interceptions he made some terrible
throws you made some awful decisions
was that him trying to do too much in
maybe but he can throw the football I
think when you look at where he'll go
yep some think Todd does I'd make
shaving so he's going to go very high I
have him at 12 or 19 to the
Raiders they have two picks in the first
round on a hunch that maybe John will
handpick the first-round quarterback for
the way the first time he's ever had
that opportunity and like I said rich if
he's if he gets into that area where he
where to what we said would be it's kind
of never-never-land and I say that
because there's no quarter no team that
really desperately needs a quarterback
if you just say New England could well
that's a 23 and then there's Hertz I
like it we're going from love to Hertz
so love does hurt sometimes the
Pittsburgh Steelers you have him at 49
well what do you why do you like that
landing spot for four Hertz and do you
think he would maybe last a shorter than
just 49 Mel Kiper he could there's talk
of New England I can't believe it 23 but
there's talk of that maybe if they trade
out of the first round they would look
at Jalen Hertz
yeah 43 career rushing touchdowns five
three of carry he gives you that ability
to have packages specifically for him
people forget Lamar Jackson was a
package quarterback early on he ever had
packages for him with Joe Flacco
starting so again you know we didn't
know what Lamar would develop into as a
pastor as concerns about the ability to
see the field for Jalen Hertz as a
passer in the NFL as a starting
quarterback but he improved dramatically
in terms of his throwing motion his
accuracy overall his justice his passing
skills look better his home you know
mechanics look better at Alabama and
they'll even look better at Oklahoma
under Lincoln Riley he didn't think
never has thrown an interception he's
been good with ball security there and
taking care of the football so I would
say Pittsburgh looking for the heir
apparent to Big Ben in the division
where Mike Tomlin has seen Lamar Jackson
he knows he's going out to deal with Joe
burrow and Baker Mayfield I think he's
there for the Steelers I keep hearing
that that's a possibility no copper
junior here a few minutes left where the
ESPN NFL Draft analysts deluxe joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show let's go
back to the top um the Giants have a
fascinating decision you know gentlemen
with his prized quarterback right there
you'd think he might want to protect him
and at 4 he's got he's gonna have he's
gonna have every name on the board he
wants but you think he goes Isiah
Simmons why do you like that pick for
the Giants Mel well I think it's a great
defensive player it's a position where
they added Blake Martinez who was a
tackling machine
coming over from Green Bay they needed
linebacker who and it's not just a
linebacker Richie's everything he can
cover tight ends he can cover receivers
he can get after the quarterback he's
got sideline to sideline range
I've got length you know he's all about
six three and a half of incredibly long
arms which is important Jon Gruden
always wanted linebackers who had that
kind of length and that kind of wingspan
and he has that break up passes you
think he thought there he is and there
all the sudden the pass is broken up and
it's not a touchdown or a long game so
Simmons has a lot of value for today's
NFL rich I think the offensive tackle is
tempting I know Daniel Daniel Jeremiah
thinks may be offensive tackle you know
with Tristan worse and they could I mean
they got to protect us
Daniel Jones has shown he's a franchise
quarterback I think you've shown that as
a rookie the fumbles I don't like any
quarterback in history the game has ever
been knocked at the end of his career
because what preventing them from being
great well you fumble too much when you
ever hear that rich never so and some of
the great quarterbacks to that fumbling
issues during their career but Daniel
will claw Jones will clean that up the
offensive lines got to protect him
better so for Dave gentlemen knowing he
has a franchise quarterback that he
drafted and Daniel Jones maybe he would
reach a little bit for the tackle but if
he doesn't then I think then he would
take the best defensive player which
will be Isaiah Simon and then you got
the Jaguars going Jerry Judy at nine Mel
do you have Judy at the top of your wide
receiver draft board - I do some think
it's Henry I know judge attention Maggie
thinks it's Henry rug's the third here's
something CD lamb from Oklahoma
Justin Jefferson LSU was fast rising
upwards after running that for 43 and
having a phenomenal year which Oboro at
LSU so I would say Judy just smooth
consistent reliable 90% of time you've
had a couple drops uncharacteristic and
we're just concentration drops but I
compared on the Marvin Harrison he's a
great route runner I was with Marvin
when I picked Marvin to go the whole
bowl of the year he come was coming out
of Syracuse we was over there in Hawaii
with me and I remember the businesslike
approach when he got in that locker room
and got on that pin we were in Hawaii
rich and it's timed up he didn't wait
part of having fun he wanted to play
football and that whole ball was a
little more relaxing some of these at
all like the Senior Bowl but he wanted
to just go out and play football and
take it seriously and that's the way
yeah he had to look you could look at
his face and say boy he's ready to play
football and that's the way I think
Jerry Judy is he's not flashy he just
goes out and does his job so
it all comes down to it Mel and this may
have something to do with whether the
dolphins do make a move at the top of
the draft or the charges make a move or
somebody might make a move at the top of
the draft for the quarterback that they
covet the ultimate question is there's
somebody pretty damn talented scheduled
to come out next year where would you
rank Trevor Lawrence in this year's
quarterback draft milk Harper jr. well
would be ahead of him his burrow
obviously saw him on the same field you
saw what happened there I mean birth
think about burrow is rich people say
well two years ago he was rated as a
late round pick well two years ago the
offense has changed dramatically from
two years ago and Joe Brady came in the
receivers also improved dramatically
Justin Jefferson
you know increased phenomenal though it
was staggering the improvement of him in
terms of his production and his
consistency
Clyde Edwards the lair became a major
factor at running back remember it was
Brissette was the running back to back
two years ago so it was a different
situation entirely and to go then play
the way he did without one game where he
left that game thinking boy is he really
that good there was never a game like
that he was over 71 percent every game
but the championship game he was a 60s
3:3 there after that struggling start he
got it together and you saw what
happened five touchdowns no picks he
slips he dips he does everything in the
pocket he's got great awareness he plays
with a chip there's not you got to put
borough one I think with two is injury
yeah you might look at that and say
Lawrence at two and then two at three
and the Herbert at four so I think
Lawrence would be just if he were in
this trap thought it could be slightly
behind borrow and certainly a head of to
it because of the injury yeah I thought
you'd say Trevor Lawrence no question
about it no stuttering but you that
borrows that special huh when it comes
down to it's impossible rich to overlook
his greatness this year and when you go
and look at the competition he's faced
and think about this the pressure he was
under to get the Heisman Trophy and then
had to go out and all eyes on you
expectations through the roof it this
was championship or bust for LSU okay
anything other than a national
championship win winning that title when
in that final game was a bust it was all
for naught and to go out and struggle
early and remember Clemson look like
they had all the answers and everything
they were doing they were look like well
I sure could be up against it here when
you get into the second quarter and from
that point on it was lights out
yeah just see adapt see changes that
Brady it was that great
have there as well with him and they had
a lot of talent but had no games
zero games where he had anything that
would make you think that there's a
chance he may not be as good as we think
he is as a lie
Joe Perot would be number one I think in
any draft and now if we look if he's not
as good as he should be I don't think I
haven't heard anybody that I respect say
yeah burrow pumped the brakes
pump the brakes he's not that good I
haven't heard anybody say that I think
the concern was early on well it's one
year you know I didn't play that great
two years ago but after the way he
played this season and played in those
pressure packed games
I think everybody's on board and I said
that's a joke burrow is a bust
I think everybody's wrong and Hoosier
for last one for you Mel Kiper jr. who's
your favorite player in this draft who's
the guy that you're you covet like you
absolutely could be borough but it could
also be somebody that we haven't even
mentioned it's off the radar screen it's
somebody's lower first-round high second
maybe even a third round or they huge
ceiling who's that guy that you say oh
man I just dig this kid I'd have to have
him on my team Creek Westeros we enter
that by like we do those who are your
favorite players I do that up on
espn.com and Totten I do that as well
and Daniel does it when I was here who
was the most fun player most
entertaining player it's more than who
you're who you're a rated player get
rated Makai Becton was fun to watch play
ty left accurate Louisville he just
wanted to just get after people and
dominate people jeff Okuda was fun to
watch how he just went to lock down and
he tackled he did everything you want a
complete corner to do I think those were
two guys that jump out and me obviously
Isiah Simmons flying all over the field
making play CD lamb with the stiff arm
after the catch I mean I call him see dy
AC because these are yards after catch
are phenomenal so those are just some of
the guys that Jeremy chin a safety at
Southern Illinois I watch them against
Western Illinois 15 tackles yet yeah 13
career interceptions at Southern
Illinois he's going in the second round
he was an interesting non 1a player to
watch he he won't be one of the first
one does the old days I called one
double a Rachel one double a days he's
one of those guys it's going to go
pretty high Jeremy chin out of southern
Illinois
okay sounds like you're ready for the
draft now I'm not gonna lie what do you
think of caliendo's impersonation you
mil you like it yes or no caliendo's
good friend I went we came and I and
Lauren what do it show and
we watch both shows we even stay for the
second show and if you ever have a
chance to do that rich he's incredibly
entertaining and it's very I mean he's
got it down I just wanted to get it I'd
like to see him get it Daniel Jeremiah
does he do you yet rich no he does not
he is the a to attempt I think he's
still stuck on Stephen H Smurf as he
calls his a stuffed animal he has in the
office I think he's stuck on that thanks
they call Mel thanks for the call really
appreciated I'm a seen you in person
that's Mel Kiper jr. ESPN NFL draft
analyst hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here